chronicles the life and career of
bodybuilder Hollywood action star and
California Governor Arnold
Schwarzenegger this is about an hour
good afternoon and welcome to today's
meeting of the Commonwealth Club of
California I am bill Adams a member of
the Commonwealth Club Board of Governors
and your chair for today we also welcome
our listeners on the radio and
television and now it is my pleasure to
introduce our speaker
and a distinguished speaker it is a
biographer and novelist and media
commentator Lawrence lamer is the offer
author of 12 books on subjects ranging
from the Kennedy family to country music
from his MO for his most recent book
fantastic the life of Arnold
Schwarzenegger
mr. lamer was given unprecedented access
to almost all of mr. Schwarzenegger
close friends and associates including
Maria Shriver and Ahnold himself in
addition to his numerous books mr. lamer
has published magazine articles in
Harper's the New York magazine
Washingtonian he has received an
overseas Press Club award for best
magazine reporting his second book
playing for keeps in Washington was
named a notable Book of the Year by the
New York Times and his book the Kennedy
women was a New York Times best seller
considered an expert on the Kennedys the
Reagan's and American politics mr. lamer
has served as a consultant for him MSNBC
and has appeared on NBC Nightly News CNN
and NPR mr. lamer is a graduate of
Antioch College and the Columbia
University School of Journalism he is
also served as a Peace Corps volunteer
in Nepal and a Ford research fellow in
Japan today he lives in Palm Beach
Florida and when he's not in Palm Beach
in Washington DC please join me in
welcoming Lawrence lamer to the
Commonwealth Club
[Applause]
well I'm delighted to be here you know
when I came to California last week and
began my book tour and I would begin my
talks with doing a little imitation of
Arnold and joking around a little bit
but in these last few days I realized
the seriousness of what Callie of
California faces in his next few months
with the initiative election and I
realized the unique opportunity I have
as the author of this book in which
Governor Schwarzenegger gave me
unprecedented access in which he
essentially we went through the entire
book I asked him questions about
everything that's in it
I interviewed Maria Shriver and
everything about her in the book I've
asked her about all the friends and
close associates the reviews I've gotten
for this book have been probably the
best in my career or at least the best
since the Kennedy Women and every single
review says that this is a fair and
balanced account of his life and saying
that I want to take before this
important audience I'd like to talk you
as California's about this man and I'm
sure there's some of you sitting here
who just love Arnall and have extremely
positive feelings about him and just so
devoted to him and there are others who
are extremely anti Arnold and just for
this time that we're sharing together I
asked you to just forget that and just
let's talk about his life let's talk
about the qualities in his life and
perhaps when we finish these minutes
together you'll have a somewhat
different perspective or a more nuanced
perspective or perhaps you won't change
at all so let's just look at the
qualities this man has his childhood his
father was an alcoholic his father beat
him as he beat his brothers he was born
in 1947 in the village of tal a tiny
village in the Styrian sent
south-central Austria his father was
considered the police chief in this town
but they're really only two police
officers in town so it's hardly right to
call him the police chief I interviewed
one of Arnold's friends who told me that
one day mr. Schwarzenegger was passed
out drunk on their honor on the grass
and he took his pulled his gun out and
shot the gun up in the in the
in the sky and and the mr. sweren didn't
didn't even wake up so he had a
difficult troubled childhood
Arnold's older brother was the favorite
brother in the family that he was the
more handsome when he was stronger he
was bigger he was the one that's
supposed to do great things in life not
poor Arnold and we're not we talked
about this and about his troubled life
Arnold said to me
don't exaggerate my childhood don't over
emphasize it don't put some kind of
Easy's Freudian spin on this he said the
key to me is that God gave me this
incredible joyous sense of life God gave
this to me he said I have friends that
take antidepressants every day and they
don't feel one one-thousandth the way I
do naturally so he had this incredible
sense of joy and he had he was a natural
extrovert there very few true extroverts
in the world this is a man who's an
extrovert who derives energy from being
but with people the more ease with you
the more energized he is he really can't
stand to be alone he's an extrovert on
the other hand he has the sensitivities
and the insights of an introvert if he
were the one talking to you today I mean
he would totally dominate this room but
at the same time he would be figuring
out each one of you who'd missed nothing
he'd come away these are the qualities
he's had as he as a child as a 15 year
old he became he started building his
body up becoming a bodybuilder and he's
a scoop of bodybuilders he's he was 15
his closest friend was 21 years old he
was a brilliant young medical student
and I when I when I heard that I said
how was this possible when I was 15 it
would be unthinkable for me to have a 21
year old friend and it certainly
wouldn't had a 21 year old friend he was
a vocational tract he was what's become
a carpenter he went to the worst high
school in Graz the city necks right over
the hill from if I'm tall and so when I
went to visit tall and grass this now
doctor is a distinguished doctor with
his own practice and I said to him
doctor girsl how could you have Arnold
as your friend and he said not only was
he my closest friend but he was the
leader of our group so those are the
kind of qualities he had he just drew
people to him he drew people to him when
he went into the army he was the leader
in his group in the army and
bodybuilding was the device that he used
to get out of grass
he's just addicted to bodybuilding he
would do it day and night he'd begin
taking steroids when his 15 years old he
he had mentor after mentor and that's
the way he advanced in life but but not
he's not a reader you hardly ever reads
books he is by getting we kept these
friendships he's mentoring relationships
and mentors used sort of fastly in
American society basically for
somebody's who's your superior at work
and helps you out his mentoring with his
profound relationships we just
essentially kind of suck the essence out
of these people and learned everything
he could from them he did this with with
this younger son with his father who was
a Jewish partisan and he's talked about
Arnold being anti-semitic not true at 15
his the his first mentor was was Alfred
gürsel who rose to become the president
of the Austrian Senate becomes a
bodybuilder and how does he do it
through this incredible sense of
discipline he yes he yes he took
steroids but nobody worked out harder
nobody worked harder than Arnold is a
bodybuilder he would bill he woke up six
work out six hours a day he would do
these repetitions until he was ready to
pass out in fact the only way he knew to
stop was that he would pass out off and
in the next time he would not go quite
to that point and in this to what the
most of us would be incredibly boring
tedious thing lifting these weights all
the time he found joy in that and he
always he would never do that alone he
always had to have a partner so he so he
built this kind of discipline and all
these things carry on as the rest of his
life I would almost call this book a man
from tall because he's still a villager
from Austria he still takes his
qualities and builds other layers on his
own life but he still has instant many
ways like an Austrian villager so he had
this kind of discipline that he
continued through his career he he had
the discipline as a movie star
he knew everything about the films he
took care of the marketing took her the
publicity he missed nothing he did this
in everything when he got $30,000 for
the first time what did he do with that
money as a young actor he didn't what
did he buy a fancy house in the
Hollywood Hills no he took that $30,000
and used it as a down payment on a six
unit apartment building he used stayed
in one of the units and he rented out
the other five and that's the beginnings
of a great
real estate fortune he didn't have to be
a movie star to be a very wealthy man
these that another quality had was a
love of police publicity and using
publicity as his engine for advance and
the quickest way to get publicity is
controversy and he sought it early on he
was not afraid of controversy as a young
bodybuilder in America
he'd never won a big prize and he called
the American bodybuilders cowards
I mean imagine calling them cowards well
got a lot of publicity a lot of
controversy he didn't care as a young
actor when who was the greatest movie
star in the world
it was sebastio Stallone so what did
Arnold do he started making fun of
Sylvester Stallone again unheard of
Sloane got very upset at that
in the meantime Arnold was made a movie
in Austria Red Sonja a terrible movie
with Brigitte Nielsen a 21 year old
Danish model and Arnold almost certainly
had an affair with her he was going out
with Maria at the time he had an affair
with her she was obsessed with him and
she wanted to marry him and to get her
off his back he and Stallone shared the
same lawyer Jake bloom and he got Jake
bloom to introduce Brigitte Nielsen to
Sly Stallone Salone married her and in
the annals of Hollywood marriages this
has to be one of the worst ever lasted
two years
so Stallone despised Arnold for two
reasons one because he he gave him his
wife is in his ex-wife and secondly
because Arnold made fun him all the time
and then Arnold gave an interview for
the playboy Playboy magazine and in this
interview and I have the 200 page
transcript of the interview he said at
the beginning you know you can ask me
anything but don't ask about Bridget
Nilson Maria trust me but believed I
just can't she's really upset by
Brigitte Nielsen just don't mention the
name and he talked off the record about
Brigitte Nielsen and he talked off the
record about Salone some more incredibly
negative things about Salone well
playboy went ahead and put these things
in the interview and Salone was so angry
that he went to it to a tabloid
journalist and told the tabloid
journalist that he knew because of his
relationship with Brigitte Nielsen that
Arnold was anti-semitic he was pro-nazi
and his father
atrocities in World War two these
appeared in the British tabloid news of
the world
Arnold sued the tabloid he served this
woman this woman went on with with
Sloan's help to write a scurrilous
biography of him that biography came out
and hid many of these charges in that
book again five years later the lawsuit
had reached the point where she was
gonna have to give a deposition and
admit that Sloan was behind all this
at that moment saloon and Arnold were to
go into partnership and Planet Hollywood
so Stallone got her a new lawyer and a
financial settlement and that was the
end of that I mentioned that to Arnold
and Arnold said he wasn't too happy I
knew that but he was he said that that
was the truth and that he and not he
doesn't blame Stallone and they became
friends again but but that's the reason
I'm telling that story is to show how he
used controversy and in that in that
instance how the use of controversy to
get publicity hurt him and hurt him in
his life and all these stories that
continue about his anti-semitism and
pro-nazi that's still out there and
that's one of the time part reasons had
a hard time getting a publisher for this
book frankly because a lot of several
publishers in New York thought it was
true but it's not true but those stories
are out there the other quality has his
manipulation of the media early on when
he was a bodybuilder in the American
bustle magazines they aren't it's not
really journalism as you and I would
call it they're these magazines that
were owned by Joe Weider
who was not was another of Ronald's
great mentors and wieder would project
these heroic enormous images of the
bodybuilders exaggerate exaggerate the
size of their bodies exaggerated
everything about them judge rate their
life sell them through the idea of sex
that if you build up your bodies you're
gonna have sex and you're going to have
not one woman you go to many room you
could have a different woman every night
and Arnold was supposedly the example of
this and so Arnold saw how you could
build this mythic image he put up his
little ads we don't let him put these
little ads for his pamphlets about the
secret techniques of bodybuilding Ronald
swartz [ __ ]
these tiny little pamphlets and all
these people started writing in sending
in their three dollars to get these
little pamphlets he started getting all
this money that way and he saw how you
could you'd have this image that only
had relatively little to do with what
you are and that's sold in America that
that you you became your own product and
he became his own product he did the
same thing as Hollywood his
his publicist with Charlotte Parker
who's become whose absolute crucial to
his career and Charlotte when they would
be these movie openings she would make
sure that his photographed only with
stars that were more important only with
the top stars not with anybody lesser so
he would use them and they wouldn't use
him she would work the lines and she
would only make sure he got interviews
with with the journalists that were
appropriate and she would tell him not
get them an idea what they should ask so
he continued to build this image of
himself and to just use the media
freedom of the press for Arnold meant
freedom for him freedom to project a
certain image of himself another quality
had is secrecy he's a man that holds
things very tightly to himself when he
came to the United States in 1968 for
the first time it's only the last minute
he came to Miami and competed in the Mr
Universe contest
he was secret in the in 1980 when he
competed for the last time the mr.
Olympia contest in Australia it's only
fair that you as a bodybuilder that you
know who your competitors are so you can
prepare to compete against them
Arnold essentially lied to the other
competitors and said he wasn't competing
he shows up in Melbourne Australia
he suddenly competes and he wins and
that's the scylla controversy to this
day of among bodybuilders I think that
was unfair but that's Arnold the kind of
secrecy the other quality has is
domination it mean as a bodybuilder he
did not simply defeat his opponents he
destroyed them I mean every opponent he
beat never came back never won another
championship he did it just alone he in
a sense defeated Stallone and Arnold
took over as the greatest action star in
the world he had a different way of
dominating men and dominating women but
he had to dominate them all a lot of
what we call groping is is in many
respects Ana's way of dominating women
joy Braun who's an hour ready to talk
psychologists in 1977 he was she was a
young journalist and he did an interview
with her and and he grabbed her leg
while they're doing the interview and
she says it's not about pot it's not
about sex it's about power and that's
what there's that he dominates the world
he dominates everything that's just the
way he looks on life he must dominate
men and women so these are the qualities
I've described and let's just look at
what happens to these
quality's as he decides to run for
governor he plans years in advance what
he's gonna do he decided he wanted to
run for governor suddenly things fell in
place he's a he's a progressive on
social issues a physical conservative if
there'd been a normal Republican primary
he might not even want but because of
the recall there he is the the Democrats
and independents vote for him
and he wins at what is essentially a
Lance Lance at election he in terms of
the media and in terms of what here's
the secrecy of it how does he announced
he announces on the on The Tonight Show
at that with nobody knowing even this
campaign manager didn't know he's gonna
announce that morning Maria finally
agreed that he could run the Maria's
problem with him running was that she
said that if he comes governor he's
gonna love this he's in love being
governor and I'm not gonna have him
anymore I'm gonna lose him forever as
the man I've known and that is
essentially is what happened and she
says you know I don't even ask for any
time for myself anymore
it's only time for my children so that
was true and that is a secrecy with his
love of his that attitude toward the
media I mean I was there during the
campaign he he he literally stiffed the
Calif or the California press the
political press there were nothing to do
with them he didn't he didn't need them
because he had the entertainment media
that treated him as a primary subject
and treated him in gloriously positive
ways and a lot of local television did
the same thing so it almost nothing to
do with print journalists that started
when he became governor some of his
advisors said that you better start
talking these reporters you better be
open to them and I think he made a big
mistake in not doing that because
although the press the print media in
California tends to be fairly liberal
and the talk showed talk radio says I'm
is on the right these reporters they're
many ideologies that like a great story
and Arnold was a great story but they
would have nothing to do with him he
would have nothing to do with them and
after his first year in office which was
largely by most estimates a fairly
successful year in office everybody in
California all the radio sites excuse me
all all the television stations all the
newspapers wanted to interview him what
did he do he turned all them down and
went on Larry King he just totally stiff
he's stiff California journalists well
California journalist a journalist
generally have
getting even and they remembered this
and now that he's in trouble he does not
have the empathetic kind of coverage he
would have now why is he in all the
trouble why have his poles dropped from
sixty five to forty percent in four or
five months there's no great crisis
there's not some terrible failure of his
why have they dropped so dramatically
well in December last December Arnold
gave a speech in a group in a woman's
group if Maria had put on this day for
women who were ten thousand women there
and he gave a speech and he he there
were group of protesters there Donald
was always seeking controversy he didn't
care he called the Democratic
legislators girly men at the Republican
convention last August the the bush
people said please don't use that phrase
again he said I may not put in my speech
but I'm going to use it and use it again
and got the biggest applause so here are
these protesters here why not fling out
a zinger to them so he looked at them
and said you know you're just special
interests and I kick your butts
well you don't kick the butts of 60,000
nurses in California the issue basically
was should there be then the the law
that was passed by great David signed by
grey Davis was going to have five five
patients for one nert for one nurse he
wanted to make it six six that was the
issue it's not an issue that brings
people into the streets but the public
employees unions the Democrats
brilliantly manipulated that and started
bringing protesters into the street then
in January Arnold gave his State of the
State speech because of his need for
secrecy and because frankly he is a very
mediocre staff he is no one for a man
who aspires to be president he is no one
the caliber of a Karen Hughes or a Karl
Rove without him George Bush would not
be President he's no more like a Ted
Sorensen and and when the State of the
State speech many of the things he said
that this would be the year of reform he
had to rescind or he had to change he
was gonna have a hundred Commission's
there was a do a 100 Commission's to Lee
Schneider who said wait a minute he
pulled that back because some of these
commissions were very good he was going
to he was going to have merit pay for
teachers he changed that and change it
to tenure for teachers are the worst of
it was he was going to change the
pension
from defined benefit pension plan to
401ks now this is the kind of thing
that's happening all over America I mean
with Americans living as long as we are
can we afford to have people after 20
years working for government get
pensions of 80 percent of their salaries
I don't know about that
I was sure as heck as a writer would
like to have that what he wanted to do
was not change it for the current
employees he was gonna change it for the
new him the new hires and again it's
something that's happening all over
America it's not some radical right-wing
scheme that he cooked up not at all it's
fully in the mainspring stream to want
to change that but the way this
initiative was written it looked as if
the fire for the widows of cops and
firefighters who died in the line of
duty would lose their pensions the
Democrats saw this immediately they knew
how poorly written this was the retinas
initiative was they kept totally quiet
and they had the right to write the way
with this this bill would appear for the
for the California voter and they
pointed out about how the widows might
lose a pension plan and Arnold backed
out of this a big problem it also this
also brought the firefighters and the
cops into the streets again why did it
do this
the this wasn't affecting them this was
affecting new employees but the public
employees units and the Democrats you
know shrewdly took advantage of this and
this is not like at one of his Arnold's
action movies or he gets up and gets out
of the trenches and kills a hundred
people ah and doesn't suffer anything
his opponents are fighting with real
bullets and indeed are fighting with
real bullets against him right now so
they took advantage of this and his
polls began to drop I think he's in
serious trouble now these initiatives to
my way of speaking the three initiatives
that he's agreed to these are not
right-wing initiatives to have tenure
for teachers after five years I mean to
me it's a very teachers should be
treated with great dignity I don't see
that this isn't gonna hurt good teachers
that they're three more years before
they get the tenure and it's gonna have
weed out bad teachers it's no big deal
maybe we shouldn't have an initiative
for this but it's not the right wing in
terms of Jarett the Jerry magnet
legislature we have this legislature now
that the Democrats and the Republicans
in 2000 do a map so that they don't
really have to run that we have we have
two parties some party some parts of the
state are total republic
some parties parts of totally democratic
that both parties politicians
Republicans didn't want this change
either it's not just the Democrats that
are upset that with this his own parties
except for this they don't want to they
don't want to have real elections they
prefer to you know to just reelected
without having much of a campaign each
time so this again to me is not is not
the right wing's totally mainstream the
third thing in the budget initiative I
mean that that's a conservative thing
and he wants to he wants to to hold if
the expenses are behind budgets he wants
a very strong way to hold that down the
Democrats on their part to my I think
they should be more honest and say that
they believe we should raise taxes we
should raise taxes or education and
let's have that out there I mean but
let's have an honest campaign so you now
as Californians are going to be facing
the most extraordinary political
campaign this state has seen for a long
long time nobody wants to face up to it
when when Arnold gave his three-minute
speech earlier to to announce this
initiative was the same day as the
Michael Jackson verdict the verdict had
been several hours before but a 501
Arnold wanted three minutes on
television he was warned that he better
choose a different time he didn't do it
and low and below as far as I know not a
novice station in the state ran this
live so California did they did later
they ran it but the only one cuts it but
the whole three minutes the big three
minutes Californians didn't really hear
that an entirety things are going he's
having a very difficult time now his
speech to Santa Monica College the kind
of protesters out there people not
letting him speak the millions and
millions of dollars coming into the
state he's gone all over the country
raising money from he doesn't call them
a special interest but their special
interests their large corporations their
wealthy people those are special
interests so it's basically his special
interests against the Democrats special
interests and the the teachers unions
that just raise the dues on teachers
they've just about 51 million dollars to
throw into the fray so you're gonna from
next few months you're gonna when you
watch television you're gonna see these
ugly ads he's ugly attacks in you as
California's are somehow gonna have to
rise above this you're gonna have to
figure these things out for your own
you're gonna have to figure out which
way to go for this I know as much as I
know about Arnold Schwarzenegger that
this is this man of joy he has to feel
joy where he's not going to do things I
add the one line I could change in my
book in the last chapter I say he's full
of joy joy like never before in his life
that is not true anymore it's a very
troubled time for him
it's a troubled time for the for the
state it's trouble time for Californians
if he loses these initiatives in
November I think he'll walk away Maria
has been talking about how oh I want my
husband home I think that's a calculated
ploy so that if he decides not to run
again he'll say well Maria wants me home
that's the reason he does inspire to
being president my book begins at the
Republican convention in August he's a
great speaker he spent more time
preparing that speech than any speaker
of either party at either at either
convention he spent hours and hours
going over rewriting and rewriting it
his idea was that that speech would
America would embrace him they would see
him as this national political leader as
the great political leader of the 21st
century he got pretty far that night
items cause some friends of mine a
Russian immigrant friend of mine from
Boston said he'd never seen a politician
speak to him as I don't spoke to him
that night millions of Americans felt
the same way I think now he could have
probably regrets that he was so honest
to me about wanting to be President and
Shaina having the Constitution changed
because he's in such deep trouble but I
would not count this man out he's an
extraordinary man he's a man of
extraordinary accomplishments it's a
difficult time it is going to be a
fascinating and divisive time for
California and I just hope because my
daughter's here lives in California my
brother lives in California I've lived
here and I just hope for all of us that
this comes out and it truly is a year of
reform if you have any questions I'd be
glad to answer them
[Applause]
I'm glad you brought that up
our thanks to Lawrence lamer biographer
and author of fantastic the life of
arnold schwarzenegger for his comments
today again I am bill Adams a member of
the Commonwealth Club Board of Governors
and I will be moderating today's
audience question period and the
questions are still coming in mr. lamer
we have a large number of questions
let's begin this just off the press
there's a lot of questions about Arnold
personally huh and let's start with this
when is Arnold a workaholic
no I know Timmy a workaholic
I might my wife might call me workaholic
but I can't I can't let up you know I
kid I always take my work with me I go
to bed I'm thinking about it he's just
the opposite in huh over the Christmas
holidays Maria called me for the
interview and she went on for two hours
talking okay
and she called two days later and said I
can't sleep at night I'm obsessed with
how I'm gonna come out in this book I
just can't sleep Arnold in the meantime
he's preparing a State of the State
speech he's out on the ski slopes having
a great time I mean that's what he's
able to do and that's one of the things
I admire about him his buddies he's kept
his old bodybuilding buddies again Maria
doesn't like them she thinks too kind of
vulgar lowlife types they're his friends
in the evenings you know wherever he is
when he's traveling he's up to one
o'clock in the morning only sleeps about
five hours a night he's spending three
hours with these guys you know having a
drink smoking a cigar
so he's not a workaholic at all he's
disciplined he's focused and that's when
I've learned from him is to have focused
to pay attention to whatever you're
doing to pay attention absolutely the
person you're talking to
none of his freakin multitasking that
that's something he has and that's why
he learns from people to extent that he
does
Arnold gives notoriously short speeches
you mentioned a three-minute speech and
most of his sentences are probably less
than six or seven words long why is that
well I think cuz he's smart because less
is more I mean most politicians they go
on way too long he wants to leave you
wanting more his stump speech during the
campaign he got
- eight or nine minutes the strangest
thing about that was these people would
stand there for two hours waiting for
him and then they were getting kind of
bored after six minutes and television
has changed their attention span but
even listen three minutes was too long
for television in California maybe
better get it down to 30 seconds well
now I had to give up weightlifting
because it got too easy but does Arnold
still workout with weights we have a
number of guys about that he's not a
weightlifter he'll tell you that right
he's a bodybuilder big difference yes I
mean this is a man who believes that
there's a spiritual quality to working
out he works out an hour a day no matter
what maybe it has to be half hour in the
morning and how far the evening and
that's one of the positive things I
think he could do even more is to get
people off their butts I mean he has an
inspirational quality about that and he
wants people to get out and exercise now
this is covered in your book but I think
it's important for listeners to hear
what was Arnold's formal educational
background and how did he get his
economic and financial skills well he
has a very minimal education he in Graz
the city that he went to you went to the
worst high school there
he had a vocational education is
supposed to become a carpenter he comes
to California
he takes courses he takes some courses
in Santa Monica College and UCLA and he
gets a correspondence degree from the
University of Wisconsin but it's not
much of an education but he's just a
quick learner I'll tell you one personal
story is my brother ed is a professor
you so as an economist and a kind of
attrition and the first week of the
campaign my brother
was he called me one of my brother to
give him information economics now my
brother went to his house and my brother
Arnold sat there for three hours
listening my brother now I love my
brother he's great but I would not want
to listen to him for three hours but you
know Arnold did why did I don't do that
because he could you thinks my brother's
terrific no he went on for three hours
because he was learning he was sucking
everything he could out of it
unfortunately and my brother told him he
should raise taxes and that was the end
of his advising but other than that you
know and that's what he does
so that's how he learns he learns
through people
he's not that he didn't go to Harvard
and Yale he's not intimidated he he
doesn't he's totally confident about
that he doesn't care about that sort of
to follow up on that it appears that
Arnold as governor is fundamentally a
fiscal conservative I think you call it
instinctive conservatism and you've now
studied him and the influences on him
from his earliest days in the little
village of tall to his you know mega
billion will make a million-dollar film
career can you tell us whether or not
his 30 years in the film industry left
him unspoiled as a fiscal conservative
or as a person well no he's a physical
first so he comes from this little
village in in tall with the natural
conservatism there that you look who
looks out for your family and friends
and that's the most important thing he's
a conservative become because he came to
this country with nothing and he's a
natural entrepreneur that real estate
fortune can starting with nothing and he
thinks and if he has one weakness I
think maybe sometimes doesn't realize
that everybody can't do this I mean
everybody doesn't have his qualities but
yes I mean truly believes this and
that's the idea of not raising taxes I
mean he's not gonna budge on that he
could have you know followed my
brother's advice and other people's
advice in his first year and my brother
said raise taxes for three years have a
poison pill so it ends after three years
and cut the public employees down to the
level was 1999 that I think was pretty
good advice but he doesn't he just that
that's the that's the Bible to him
you're not gonna raise taxes whatever
like I note that in the little village
of tall and put up a plaque to him and
they've repainted his house where his
family where he grew up and one question
I asked Austrian seemed thrilled to see
Arnold elected but is his unwillingness
to oppose the death penalty has that
gone well and is he still popular in
Austria well there's a group of leftist
politicians who wanted the the football
stadium in Graz
I know under which was the body but was
the gym where he worked out as a young
man they wanted it was named Arnold
Schwarzenegger Stadium and they wanted
to take that away because he was
approving of the death penalty that
didn't happen but he's overwhelmingly
popular Nasser and actually his dual
citizenship he doesn't talk much about
that but he has dual citizenship and he
could go back to Austria and be
president of Austria I don't think Maria
would like living there but in a day
could do that well in addition to the
questions about Arnold the personal
questions and we'll turn to the
political ones a little later there's a
number of questions asking about you and
and how you see things one question I
asked your book is very comprehensive
and fair which is something with which I
agree and it took great time and
distance to compile the information and
ensure validity were your efforts in any
way financially supported by any Kennedy
or Schwarzenegger dollars but don't I
wish I could use it I'm available and I
finished it any money money no you know
I make my living as a writer I get I get
an advance and I had a very difficult
time doing this at the beginning I was
kicked out of an early campaign event I
was told my credentials were danique
good I physically was thrown out and I
called Murray oh I've known for years
and I said to complain and she said
don't be a wimp this happened to me John
McCain threw me out of an event in 2000
go out and do your job so I went on did
my job and you know that there was a
campaign it was a bus trip at the end of
the campaign there were four buses and I
was the fourth bus was the zoo bus which
is all the technical people and I was on
the reporter on the zoo bus so they
weren't terribly excited about me doing
this I think for several reasons one is
on elects control and he couldn't figure
out a way to get control of this
secondly he likes money he is His image
and he couldn't figure out a way to get
money out of this that he thought he did
how could anybody put his his picture on
the book and he should get a cut of this
well he's getting not getting it out of
it he hasn't seen the book thirdly he
didn't like that I'd written three books
on the candidates because he doesn't
think of himself as a Kennedy and
frankly he doesn't like a lot of the
candidates a lot of the Kennedys don't
like him so those three things were were
against me but in the end when I
finished the book he began to talk and
and they asked to see the galleys but I
wouldn't show it to them so they saw the
book I got the first copy of the book
and I was gonna send it to him and then
I thought you know you better not do
that because I know what's gonna happen
is he's gonna get it and Maria's gonna
grab and he'll never see it see
we have two copies so I got two copies
and sent one to him and Sacramento and
one to her in Santa Monica so I think he
probably read it or at least looked at
it well this is something that you've
done over and over again I think in your
writing career and that is you've built
relationships and Trust with the people
that you are writing about and those who
surround them how do you do that and how
do you get the kind of access that seems
to appear in your books well I think the
key if I can advise young journalists I
would say your honor is the most
important thing you never can break your
promises to people and you don't realize
how that travels and people get to know
that and sometimes have a hard time
because there are some writers that go
around and they just lie to people I
take advantage and they misquote them
and you come around and wedding
interview them and they don't want to do
it so I don't think I've had anybody
that I'm gonna don't sound like brag but
I don't think of anybody that's coming
accused me of betraying their
confidences and I've had a lot of
confidence even on this book there are
confidences that people have given me
that that aren't that aren't out there
another personal question what are your
personal favorite pastimes I love to
play tennis I'm a reader I'm you know
just and my work I mean I worked very
hard in this book to do it is I think
I'm so fortunate to do this because
you're just sharing people's lives
I mean I've shared this man's life now
it's just I mean I've been paid to do
this
I've been paid to get to know him to
know these fascinating people I mean I I
feel I'm very very fortunate
well you're well-known as a careful and
thorough researcher and what if any
revelations about Arnold Schwarzenegger
turned up in your research that
surprised you the most I don't know if
there's anything well you talk about
Calvary I just went aside there's one
Mis statement in my book and I have to
admit this Ardant possible misstatement
I Maria was very heavy when she started
dating Arnold and I was told by several
of her friends that she weighed 170
pounds and when I asked Maria Maria how
heavier you were your heaviest she said
150 pounds
well I'm enough of a gentleman that it's
150 pounds in the book I assure you so
that's my that's my one misstatement
other than that I don't think there's
one thing I think it's a book full of
revelry
I just think that the journey of his
life is what's fascinating yeah there's
a lot of the groping stories and there's
a lot of sexual things and I'm so
delighted that the way this book has
been published is that
what typically happens is the tabloids
pull this stuff out and they put it on
the cover I'm just thinking of this
right now you know why did that didn't
happen and that's one of the key things
in this book because in July of 2003
right before I'm declared he met with
David pecker the CEO of American media
and American media owns all the tabloids
and had just purchased the bodybuilding
magazines and at that meeting David
pecker needed Arnold's help with the
bodybuilding magazines his Arnold's
faces on the cover and I wrote a column
for it and Arnold need needed David
peckers help to stop these sexual
stories and the tabloids so nothing and
I asked Arnold about this about what
happened to that meeting and he said and
that's the way things happen at the
highest level if you could call the
conspiracy call whatever you want at the
highest level a word isn't even said so
they had this meeting today that day in
Arnolds off in Santa Monica not a word
was said but the result of that was that
Arnold supported the bodybuilding
magazines continuous columns and from
that day forth
there was nothing negative no more
sexual stories and the tabloids just the
opposite it was unbelievable what
happened to the campaign the National
Inquirer on the star compared arm to
Abraham Lincoln in George Washington
there was even a special separate
magazine that they put out glorifying
Isla Negra but imagine if the Los
Angeles Times did something like that or
the San Francisco Chronicle would be
outraged but they did that and that was
the deal that continues to this day and
and the deal was even formalized
recently and now Gong gets $250,000 a
year that he gives forchette for charity
as the executive editor of the two big
bodybuilding magazines you've written at
length about Arnold Schwarzenegger is 34
year career in the movie industry from
the earliest days I think he was billed
as Arnold strong I don't know where they
got the name strong well just kidding
and his lines had to be dubbed in for
him at least in a couple of his early
movies how does that how do you
for his rise to being a major action
hero in earning 12 15 and 20 million
dollars a picture and his outside
success in Hollywood well I mean look
it's the most unlikely movie star of all
time but he but he knew you know he took
Eric Morris is a great acting teacher
probably the best acting teacher in
Hollywood and I one day with ten in one
of the classes for six hours it's just
exhausting because the technique is to
make these young actors come forth and
expose their emotional vulnerabilities
whatever is the the most emotionally
vulnerable thing you have to expose that
in front of the other actors see if you
can really act and he before Arnold was
a co-star I moved home called stay
hungry which could be the title of my of
my buck book stay hungry uh when he's
preparing for that he had one-on-one
classes with with Morris and Morris said
that he would never talk about his
father he couldn't bring himself that
was the most painful thing in his life
and that he to become a really good
actor he had to deal with his father he
wouldn't do it and he and went and later
he went to a group class and he said he
just got up in furious I'm out of here
I'm not gonna become an actor I'm gonna
become a star and that's what he chose
to do and he's not a great he's a lousy
actor in a traditional sense but he's a
physical actor and when he did to Conan
the Barbarian he spent months you know
learning the sword fighting learning how
his walks he's very calculating the
business on the side but he's but it's
fascinating me the way he walks
you watch he always walked slowly
because it has dignity and strength you
never gonna see this man run anywhere
that's just part of it that the physical
presence in the Terminator films I'm in
Terminator 2 I think is one of the
greatest action pictures ever again he
pulls it off because of incredible
physical presence that he has and he
worked very hard getting that and
developing that works very hard indeed
and pushing him to be the greatest star
and other reasons became the greatest
star is because he chose his projects
very carefully he chose the directors
James Cameron was probably as his
favorite director and he in the
marketing of it he was the first star to
understand the rest of the world at that
time how most of the most of the
business was in the United States nobody
wanted to go abroad Arnold was going to
Australia in your
when no other star would would and he
became the fruit incense the first
worldwide star Museum in Feynman more
famous as star outside of the United
States his insight in the 1987 film the
running man
Arnold's character a fellow named Ben
Richards says I'm not into politics I'm
into survival now in real life he's into
both politics and survival do you think
he has the character and fortitude to
survive the political forces that are
arrayed against him today in California
boy that's a great question there's a
$64 question right there does he have
the fortitude to go on this is a man who
as I said always has to have a feeling
of joy he has to have that feeling of
joy to to continue with his life he's
not feeling joy now it's a very deeply
troubling time does he have the
fortitude what's so fascinating to me
you see is this is a self-made man as
much as you can have a self-made man
there it is he's done this started with
nothing on his own his self-made - in
his problems the problems now that he
that he is facing he's created them he's
the one that has this mediocre staff
he's the one that has the fired people
he's the one that has made these kind of
cracks that have gotten him his trouble
and he's the one that can pull it out he
is perfectly capable of grasp but he's
but he's alone he's alone now he is
nobody really to advise me even his wife
he has to figure this out for himself
he's got to figure out a way to win this
this this election in November can he do
it yes but that indeed is the big
question
well you've studied and profiled another
former Governor of California Ronald
Reagan and now of course Arnold
Schwarzenegger as the novelty of arnold
schwarzenegger of as governor is
beginning to wear off and the reality
and difficulties of politics are setting
in is there anything that any advice or
lessons that he could learn from the
Gipper that might help him in his future
political actions I hate to say this but
the Gipper raise taxes in California we
don't like to talk about that but he did
and so did Pete Wilson but the gutter
but I was not going to do that although
the education my daughter's sitting down
here is a fifth-grade teacher in San
Leon
and believe me her class could use some
more money among other things yeah what
else should I say that that oh well I
mean get again there's a similarity
between the two of them they both had
alcoholics fathers they both have this
incredible sense of active optimism
they both had difficult times when
Ronald Reagan you know who thought of
his age that he would become possibly
come president the United States he hung
in there I mean it took a man of immense
abyssion ambition and drive to continue
as he did and and all the troubles of
his first administration to go on and to
have whatever you think of his politics
one of the most important presidents of
the twentieth century and most of the
transformative presidents so I say
there's nowhere better to look than
Ronald Reagan and you just hang in there
and you hang in there and you do what
you do best and just gonna come back to
you well Arnold has said he wants to be
a transformative governor but many
people believe that one of the things he
needs to learn is the ability to
compromise are the two in such a clash
that he will not be able to put them
into some consonant form and and forge
ahead well in his first year he did a
pretty good job of compromise he could
work with John Burton in the Senate the
budget you know it didn't it was a
worthy compromise his reform of workers
compensation that was the worthy
compromise I think the problem of the
second term the second year basically is
now we're up against these really tough
tough issues there are two sides of this
i'm the democrats essentially basically
they want to raise taxes they're not
going to admit it honestly as they
should they want to raise taxes they
want to give it part of it to education
they I personally probably would go
along with that but they aren't going to
do the other half of the equation
they're not control you're gonna reform
the system I mean I gave a talk
yesterday in Sacramento this man came up
to me who works and works with the
government in Sacramento he's a lawyer
he's a lawyer and to hear him talk about
what government is like talk about the
dysfunctional nature of government and
how difficult is to reform something I
mean this state has to be reformed at
the firm it has to be reformed and we've
got to get a different kind of
government got
people more responsible to the needs of
the individual citizen and Arnall is the
outlet is that is that is the horse we
have at this point if he loses okay
let's say he loses an initiative in
November and he backs out what do we
have we have a Republican Party that
will retreat back into permanent
minority state status you'll have the
extraordin to the stream the the
toughest right-wing part of the party is
saying we told your show we never should
have backed this guy back it goes to the
to the far-right you have the Democratic
Party totally beholden to the public
employees unions if they have a power in
California now wait they will say
rightfully we're the one that brought
this guy down we're the one that raised
51 million dollars the teachers union
we're the ones up through our money we
risk this we deserve to be happy at the
right seat of hano government and
they'll be there and I think the real
reform of California needs will not come
from either side you mentioned that
Arnold has possibly been planning for
some kind of a political career for a
long time when did those political
ambitions begin and what contributed to
them well years ago he had this game
plan he wanted to go into politics I
mean years ago he talked to his friends
maybe 20 years ago a big puppy income
governor until a lot of people seemed
just nothing more than a pipe dream but
it wasn't he plans what he does okay
first of all he focuses totally on what
is in front of you you focus totally on
that person that idea whatever it is at
the same time he is a vision way out
ahead of him and that it's not a dream
it's a dream to everybody else it's a
total fan is it's not to him and he
reaches for it and he gets things are
impossible be getting out of the Little
Village becoming biggest body bill in
the world be the biggest star in the
world being governor of California he
reaches for these things and what he
takes and what I've learned
really I've surely learned this is not
to be afraid to move forward I mean III
haven't been afraid because of he's a
freelance writer I mean you have to take
a lot of chances but believe me I've
learned I take more chances I'm going to
the hundred percent now I mean that's
what I've learned from this man well no
how is it that Arnold can stay a
Republican and still be married to Maria
Kennedy part of the Kennedy family a
Democrat and still survive the family
well first of all this is this a strange
thing is Ronald Reagan when Reagan
became a Republican he sense he changed
his friends and he had the kind of brain
trust of these you know wealthy callous
Southern California businessmen these
were his friends Arnold I don't think
has a single Republican friend I mean
when he would he would give these
parties in Sun Valley or la the
Hollywood types are there there's
probably not a Republican in the world
in that room so he's lived in this
Democratic world you know if he weren't
a Republican if he'd become a Democrat
being bored married to Maria Shriver he
would have been Governor of California a
long time ago
so you true truly believes these things
he's a true true Republican
how can he deal with in that family but
you know Ted Kennedy doesn't like him
you're not gonna hear that publicly but
Ted Kennedy doesn't like him at all
and Arnold really doesn't like Ted and a
lot of the Kennedys are kind of jealous
of him last year my book sons of Camelot
48 hours did an hour-long program on my
book and Anthony Shriver said that will
Arliss not a really a member of our
family Wow
so there's not there's not some bad
blood there I must say it's not going to
be out there publicly but it's there you
mentioned in your book that it took
Maria to convince him to take out a
possibly intemperate joke about Teddy
Kennedy's weight from his convention
speech oh yeah I mean the joke that I
wanted to tell which would have brought
the Republican convention down was to
say people ask me do I still work out of
course I still work out I lifted 270
pounds last week I lifted Ted Kennedy
out of a chair now great Chuck Wright
but no Murray says no no no so that was
that was cut yeah yeah that Landon part
of the speechwriter was very unhappy
about that he's the one who told me that
so that's how girly man got that's like
really mad what girly man he left girly
man in there but can't offend the
Kennedys well now there's a lot of
questions about the potential future of
Arnold Schwarzenegger in politics and
perhaps even for higher office I'm
trying to think of a presidential
candidate who's admitted to using
steroids has you know a history of
affairs and are groping with women when
a wall while in the military has a
Stormtrooper father and is undergone
heart surgery who is a viable candidate
we left out one he'll be the first
president with the full frontal nude on
the internet yes I don't think there's a
full frontal nude of Abraham Lincoln
last time I looked but so yeah this is
an amazing background to be president
but this is America I mean who would
have thought that after those groping
charges that he could be elected
governor I mean it's to me it represents
the kind of Europeanisation of American
politics that people said well he did
these things he's mitad to it and let's
move on that wouldn't have happened in
American side even ten years before Oh
Bernard was campaigning for governor his
original statement was he was going to
use all his own money for the campaign
and later on in the midst of the
campaign I believe he began using a good
deal of contributed money what if any
effect did this have on on his
credibility and how did he reconcile
that well this is one thing you learn
from the Kennedys the Kennedys learned
never spend your own money get up there
and say you're doing good with the world
but believe he doesn't come with your
own pocket so yeah he said he was into
that originally and then he backed off
and he's raised all this money he's
going around the country raising you
know tens of millions of dollars but not
his own money and again he could get
away with things that nobody else can
get away with I mean just another
example of this a few years ago he was
giving a speech in Austria and his
mother was sitting in the podium next to
him and he said you know what I liked
about Austrian women is they're such
great butts now if I had said that or
you had said that they would have hauled
us away with his mother sitting there
but he can get away with that now in one
way it's kind of disarming and it's kind
of charming in a way that he can say
things that northern politician give the
got away with it but example example of
that but as I've tried to explain this
in some way it's caught up to him and
the Democrats have taken advantage of
some of these statements he's made
well now you mentioned earlier that
Arnold Schwarzenegger has not in your
view surrounded himself with enough
top-notch political advisors how where
is he of the need to upgrade those
around him if if that's an issue for him
well first of all we're not discussing
it with not about this but in this past
he can't say no okay
and he only says yes even to me said yes
he'd grant me an interview just means
everything from get lost - lets get in
the jacuzzi
he's yes to me if for my first interview
was get lost and I didn't get in the
jacuzzi that's for sure since the
interviews were on the phone but it
changed so he can't say no and he can't
fire people his publicist and his agent
he wanted to get rid of them he didn't
do it but what he did was it began so
slowly torturing them treating them
badly until he got the message that
unfortunate is what's happening now in
Sacramento with some of these people
they're very insecure in their positions
they rightly should be the most Paul
miner who probably was his best
political a it is left to go to work for
General Electric the the most
influential advisors are these campaign
consultants and that's kind of
unfortunate and unusual and elected
official because they naturally want to
push campaigns and they're making a heck
of a lot of money off of this and I know
in Sacramento yesterday and I had a lot
of phone calls of people a lot of
Republicans are getting upset they're
upset there's no campaign headquarters
why because these people they like to
work out of their own offices so my
guess is that he's brought in some new
people he has a press staff none of whom
have ever worked for in journalism not
none of them really appreciate they just
pushed journalists off when I when I
finished my interviews with Arnold I
wanted to talk to some of the staff
members and I instead of calling them
individually I knew I better call Rob
Stutzman there's the director of
communications because they would call
him and get approval and I said electing
to view some staff members he said no
we're not going to give any interviews
until Arnold's no longer governor well
that's just foolish you've got a you've
got a case to make you've got you've got
some positive things to say about your
governor get out there and make that
make them two reporters reporters are
are not bad people they're trying to do
their job help them do their job I
probably should mention that you're
listening to the Commonwealth Club
California radio program or watching it
we hope on c-span as well and our
speaker today is Lawrence lamer
biographer and author of fantastic the
life of Arnold Schwarzenegger
now one questioner asks about what do
you mean by the word fantastic you mean
it because it
is perhaps one of Arnold's favorite
words or do you consider him a fantastic
person well I consider him a fantastic
character brother he's a fantastic
person you gotta decide when you read my
book I guess but fantastic is his
favorite word and when he was he alone
three and a half million dollars to his
campaign and the judge said that he had
to pay the money back he's a fantastic
that's fantastic news so everything is
fantastic
everything has a positive the spin to it
Joe Joe Matthews is a terrific report
young reporter of the Los Angeles Times
and did an article about a year ago
talking how that was Allen's favorite
word and showing all the time he used it
well poor Arnold limit I think he almost
had a nervous breakdown because he
couldn't use that word anymore
so he have said terrific it doesn't work
and I saw on his three-minute speech
earlier this week he's reverted he can't
resist it he said fantastic again
fantastic he said it again notice how
I've stayed away from mostly doing my
Austrian immigrants you're alive now
getting back to again the business
you're in which is writing and dealing
with famous personages is there a
celebrity perhaps Arnold or someone else
who is perhaps your most interesting
figure that you have dealt with in depth
I think our Liz is the most interesting
frankly in the sense I think I've
learned more personally from his life
and you know it's not just him it's the
people around him and another quality
has you see his great friends
I mean he's loyal to them over the years
they're old friends he doesn't have new
friends these friends go back to the 60s
with him Franco Columbu is a
chiropractor who he knew and he was in
Munich that's an example many of these
bodybuilding friends most most most of
them are old timers and you know as
Albert bucyk and Munich goes back even
that time he comes visit
Alfred Gerstel who's now in his 80s as
mentor was here a few months ago and
arnold signed a photograph to him to my
second father and i all spent a lot of
time with dr. Gerstel a lot of time he
took him to he just recently remarried
he took him to Las Vegas for the wedding
anniversary again
the arm has his human qualities that a
lot of politicians don't have i mean
politicians use the word friend all the
time but muslim don't have any or have
very few this guy would everything about
his politics he really has real friends
he's law to them well we have time only
for one more question unfortunately and
we've reached that point in the program
so i don't know if this is the the most
salient question of all but it's a
question again about you where do you go
next which families do you find
interesting where are you going to apply
your talents next well I'm desperately
looking for a topic I mean that's where
it always is actually I was I was gonna
go do a book on women in the military
before I was doing this I spent four
months just working so hard on that and
I couldn't sell the book the publisher
said there was be no market for that I
was just devastated so luckily I Arnold
came into view and I was able to do that
so I'm very happily married my wife else
is sitting there sitting here and if we
if we continue to have a happy marriage
that it's going to be because I find the
new subject well our thanks to Lawrence
lamer biographer and author of I'll try
it fantastic got a UH the life of Arnold
Schwarzenegger for joining us and we
also thank our audiences here on the
radio and on television and no I'll try
to and this meeting of the Commonwealth
Club of California is celebrating over a
century of enlightened discussion is
adjourned
[Applause]
Lawrence lemur is the author of the
Kennedy Man and the Kennedy women his
latest book fantastic the life of our